I - thanks for joining us that's what
happened like sir Danny was 29 he was
playing professional with B League and
and he had an undiagnosed heart
condition that we knew nothing about and
to to the outside world and to us he was
very healthy young fit he was doing
everything right and he was only five
six minutes into the game and he
suffered a massive cardiac arrest and
unfortunately the the extent of the
damage was too much and he wasn't able
to be saved and as a result I mean
obviously desperately sad and you had to
just yeah a baseball twins yes Phoebe
and mother yes okay okay an incredibly
challenging stressful terrible time for
you then you learned more about what had
happened to him what and the condition
yeah obviously slowly and with with
having to see the doctors and seen
experts we learned very quickly and what
what had happened and that it was a
hereditary condition and the twins could
be could be vulnerable to it as well
will we start keeping on top of that and
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy and what is
that and so Danny had an enlarged her so
being a sportsman and putting his hat
into it under a lot of pressure he's how
it was up started working backwards and
so he was doing everything right for but
you know what would be right for
generally forfeiting healthy people but
for Danny in the condition that he had
and being self it being so healthy work
backwards and and that's that's what
killed him and his heart was three times
the size that it should have been when
he died and that is obviously something
that you can't do you don't detect you
know no generally the the effect it's
found in families through a tragedy and
through somebody young dying and Danny's
family been tested and there's three
members of the family that also have the
gene they're perfectly fine and you know
they will be fine now because of Danny
and but yeah it's a hereditary condition
and how do people need to change their
lifestyle as a result of that um you
know it's really difficult isn't it
because you don't want to tell people
not to be fit and healthy it's really
hard but I guess it's just you know
looking for signs finding out about your
family history I know my dad had a heart
attack just before Danny died and when
the doctor said do you have any family
history said no but actually turns out
he do it though there is some family
history sir I think knowing your family
no we
your body and listening and and and you
know going to the doctors go into
screenings that the the charity the
Danny Jones defibrillator for now we've
screamed nearly a thousand people with
cardiac through cardiac screening and
you know there's always ten percent of
every one hundred that come back with
something and we found a couple of car
of cardiac genes now through the screen
in as well so you know if you see
something like that seeing opportunity
balk on you know it might cost you
thirty pounds it might cost you 60 you
know depending on on the day and who's
organized it but they're just the most
precious opportunities and they form
does that screening to take what's it
like so through the charity we screen a
hundred people at once and it's just
sort of a big event on one day people
sign up generally we've done it through
rugby clubs and obviously with the
charity that's where where the charity
began and but we've just done a running
my local running club and in Halifax
were screen ninety nine people and
eleven came back with further to need
him further tests one was told to stop
running immediately and on the day so
yeah that's what form does the test take
what I'm sorry so you have an ECG right
and then if anything comes back from the
ECG you then have an echocardiogram and
then you get every single person that
has an ECG gets to see a cardiac
consultant so that process can be
expensive it is expensive it costs about
six thousand pounds to screen effect a
hundred people and we like to provide as
much money as we can to get the cost
down and funders are raised money to pay
towards it but generally people just
need to contribute a little bit towards
being screened you know for someone like
me you'd pay anything now because it's
touched me personally and you know I
understand it can be expensive but you
know to get your family screened and get
to have that knowledge you know even if
there is something wrong a I've spoken
to so many people that have found scary
conditions but you know they're going to
be okay because they've been screened
Danny never had that opportunity even
playing for professional spark
he was never screened